Every time you meet someone new, people
unconsciously determine your level of
status, how successful you are, how
credible you are, and whether you're
someone worth listening to. And they
make that judgment in two different
ways. The first is through your visual
image. This is what you wear. This is
the way you carry yourself. This is your
physical appearance. If you look good,
you've got great posture, and you're
smiling, people assume you're confident
and friendly. But the moment you open
your mouth and then you speak, you now
reveal your vocal image. This is the
part people rarely think about. It's the
impression people form about you based
on how you use your voice.
[clears throat] And when they hear your
voice, they start to form beliefs about
who you really are, your credibility,
your conviction, and whether or not they
should take you seriously. But after a
decade of training some of the biggest
organizations around the world, teaching
millions of people to improve their
vocal image, I've learned there are five
common communication traits [music] of
high-status people that if you start
adopting, you'll sound like someone
people trust, respect, and want to
listen to.
>> [music]
>> Starting with trait number five, they
speak with conviction. High-status
communicators use their voice in a way
that makes you believe in what they say.
You trust their words more. They sound
like someone who has a lot of
credibility and authority. Low-status
communicators, they sound unsure and
sometimes even apologetic for taking up
space. When I was in my late 20s, I
moved from Australia to America to build
my career as a keynote speaker and as a
communication skills coach. And for
those of you watching who are not from
Australia, here in the land down under,
we do something called uptalk, where we
end every single sentence on a high
pitch. It sounds like this. Do you
notice that? Everything I say finishes
on a high note? That's completely normal
here in Australia. It's our way of
checking the listener is still with us,
and subconsciously, we're signaling to
others that we are cooperative and that
we're not trying to dominate the
conversation. However, in the US, it's
often misread as a lack of confidence
and insecurity. Anyway, before I even
knew that I had uptalk, I would enter
those important conversations with my
clients in America pitching my services
and I'd say things like, "I've been
teaching communication for the last 10
years and I'm certain I can help you
solve all your communication problems."
Did I sound high status? It sounded like
I was asking for permission and approval
the entire time. It felt like I wasn't
really doing myself justice at all,
right? I was lucky that one of my
clients called me out on this and she
said, "We would love to work with you,
but for your own sake, say it like you
mean it, dammit." And so I got another
opportunity to speak to the committee
again and this time I said it like this,
"I've been teaching communication now
for the last 10 years and I'm certain I
can help you solve all your
communication problems." That tiny
behavior change in ending my sentences
on a lower pitch completely transformed
the way I came across to my clients and
it made me feel way more confident about
what I'm saying. Uptalk is so ingrained
as a habit for so many people and rarely
is it because you're insecure. Often
it's just because it's a habit you've
been repeating for the last 10 years and
now you no longer even notice it. Look
at this example of one of my students
that I was coaching and watch how hard
it was for him to change the habit.
>> You also go up at the end of your
sentences. So I want you to end on lower
now, all right?
>> The story that I would like to share
with you is a story from my childhood.
So I was in grade five.
>> Up. Five.
>> The story that I would like to share
with you is a story from grade five.
>> Up. You're still going up. YOU'RE STILL
GOING UP. You're going grade five.
And the story I'd like to share with you
Keep it down.
>> The story from grade five
>> No, no, NO, NO, YOU'RE STILL DOING IT.
YOU'RE STILL DOING IT. SO YOU IT IS IT'S
CHRONIC. So here's the thing. What I
would like you to do is The story I'd
like to share with you is from when I
was in grade five.
>> The story that I would like to share
with you is a story in grade five.
>> Good.
>> We were tasked with this
where we had to write an advertisement
for the radio.
>> Good.
>> Did you see how many times I had to call
him out on his ending pitch? Trait
number four, they don't use 100 words
when five will do. We all have that one
person in our life who says a lot
without saying much at all. You ask them
a question and then they talk for five
whole minutes straight without actually
answering the question or saying
anything meaningful. Basically, every
damn politician you can think of these
days. This is such a common occurrence
in workplaces as well, even in my
office. Every time we're in a meeting, I
ask Andy, my head of marketing, a simple
question. Can you give me a quick update
on the campaign progress? And instead of
giving me a quick update, he somehow
turns it into a full 30-minute
investigation, cross-referencing three
campaigns [music] from the last quarter,
interviewing witnesses, and presenting
evidence to me like he's trying to solve
a murder.
Okay, I know that B-roll was dramatic,
but what I'm referring to here is the
habit of injecting more words and
context into a situation in a given
moment than is necessary. This is called
message density. Think of every
conversation like a container that holds
your message. The more words you pack
into it, the more the other person has
to do the hard work to find out what the
actual point is. In psychology, they
call it cognitive load. It's the mental
effort required to process information.
And the more words you use, the heavier
the load becomes. Whereas the less words
you use, the clearer your message
becomes and the more weight each word
will actually carry. High-status
communicators get this right. They know
what point they want to communicate and
they know the most effective path to be
able to get there. And usually, it's
simple as saying less instead of more.
And the simplest way to say less is to
use a communication framework. And the
one that I want to teach you that I use
all the time when I'm put on the spot to
answer a question is called PAT. PAT, P
A T. The P stands for pause.
Now, pause for a few moments when you
start. Think about your answer. Most
people don't do this. They answer
immediately out of nervousness and then
they blurt out the first thing that
comes to mind. And they have this fear
that if I don't answer straight away, I
might look incompetent. In my opinion,
when you do this and answer straight
away, it makes you look like you didn't
put much thought into your answer at
all. So, do what most don't. Pause
first. Give yourself a couple of seconds
to collect your thoughts. Then if you
need more time to think, you can buy
yourself even more time with the next
part of the framework, which is ask a
question. Specifically, ask a clarifying
question to get more specific. Imagine
this little weird cloud vague circle
that I'm drawing. Imagine it represents
their original question. When you ask a
clarifying question, a follow-up
question, what you're doing here is
you're getting them to draw a smaller
circle inside it. This makes the blast
radius much smaller and it makes it
easier for you to get to the answer
they're actually seeking. Because if you
answer their original question, the
reason you use so many words to answer
and give extra context is because you're
answering all of that. The moment you
ask the clarifying question, now you
know exactly what they're after. You're
using less words because there's so much
more focus in your response. And
finally, the last part of PAT, T stands
for the one thing. Once they've
clarified their question and you are
more clear on what they're asking, you
can start your answer with the phrase
the one thing. And what this does is it
filters all of the thoughts you have
about whatever is being asked and it
forces you to choose one single point
that matters the most. And this makes
your communication more clear, more
concise, and more coherent. Now, let's
go back to the example with Andy and
watch him use the PAT framework to
answer my question. Andy, can you give
me a quick update on the campaign
progress?
>> Just so I'm clear, are you most
interested in overall performance or
specifically how the new landing page is
converting?
>> Yeah, I'm actually more curious about
how the landing page is converting.
>> The one thing you need to know is that
the new landing page without your face
in it is actually outperforming the old
one where you had your face in it by
about 200% on conversions.
>> Wait, so what you're saying is
I'm ugly?
>> No, no, no. It's not what I'm saying,
it's what the data is saying. Around 2
billion people, it's basically
undeniable at this point.
>> Uh if you're a fellow ugly person like
myself, we're already hard to look at.
So we want to make ourselves at least
easy to listen to. So if you want to do
that, you got to learn communication
frameworks. If you click the link below
or scan the QR code, I've recorded a
2-hour free training on three of the top
communication frameworks that helps you
sound more clear, concise, and coherent.
I'll see you in class. #ugosunite.
Remember what I said at the start, most
people don't think about their vocal
image, they leave it up to chance.
Traits five and four will dramatically
improve your vocal image immediately,
but only if you apply it. So apply it
this week. In your next conversation,
end your sentences on a lower pitch and
then use the PAT framework and watch
people start to give you respect and
attention that you deserve. Don't be
like 99% of the population who gets
stuck in the cycle of consumption. If
you apply what you learn here on this
YouTube channel, you're already ahead of
most people. So go and do it. Now if
traits five and four upgrade your vocal
image, this next one, trait number
three, will help you upgrade your visual
image. High status communicators aren't
afraid of holding eye contact. Every
time you watch a video of your favorite
creator online, hopefully it's me, where
are they looking? They're looking
directly into the lens of the camera
which cuts through your screen into your
eyes. And think about where you're
looking the most while I'm speaking.
You're looking into my eyes, aren't you?
Eye contact doesn't just hold your
attention, it builds a physical bridge
between you and the other person,
whether it's in person or whether it's
on camera. And you can actually feel the
connection, the energy, the emotion, and
the information hitting you on the other
side of the screen. Imagine I'm talking
to you the whole time as you're watching
this video as I look over here. Or what
if I was looking over there like this up
high? Or what if I was doing this? What
if I was looking at you like this while
I was talking to you? How does that make
you feel? Okay, I know nobody does that
one, but even if I just look slightly
off the screen and don't give you eye
contact. Do you notice the difference?
Do I seem confident or do I come across
a little uncertain?
The same goes for in-person
interactions, like I said before. Strong
eye contact communicates physical
presence. It tells people, "I'm here,
I'm with you, and I'm not hiding from
this moment." And when people feel that
from you, they respect you more. They
take your words more seriously. Great
communicators understand this. They get
it. And they aren't afraid to say what
they need to while holding eye contact
with you. Now, I know a lot of people
find eye contact a little bit awkward
where you're holding eye contact for a
little too long and you suddenly zone
out the conversation and your inner
thoughts get louder and louder and you
start thinking to yourself, "Am I
staring at this person for too long?
Should I look away? Do I look weird?
What do I do? Ah!" So, if this is you,
here's a little hack that I use to help
me get a little more comfortable with
extended periods of eye contact. If you
find yourself being uncomfortable with
eye contact, let me teach you something
known as the triangle
>> [laughter]
>> technique.
>> [snorts]
>> Where basically, you look at their left
eye, then you look at their right eye,
then you look at the bridge of their
nose. And by doing this, you give your
brain something to do, so removes the
discomfort.
Thanks, Batman.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, Dan. That's why we love you. You're
the first we sacrifice every time,
especially your face. Okay, so that's
how you can get more comfortable with
eye contact when you're speaking to
somebody new. Now, if you're in a group
setting though, unlike that one-on-one
situation, in a group setting, well,
what do you do? This is what you
shouldn't do first. Don't dart your eyes
around the room too fast. It makes you
look shifty. Don't scan from left to
right, right to left. You end up looking
robotic. Don't follow the same pattern
where you look at person A, then B, then
C, then back to person A, B, then C
again. It seems weird. It seems
unnatural. Don't look over people's
heads. That's the worst advice ever
given. Don't fixate on just one person
when there are many other people in the
room because that goes from connecting
to now you're just staring. Instead of
this, this is what you should do.
Singular eye contact. Hold one person's
gaze for the length of a sentence or a
single idea. Then move to somebody else,
so it feels like you're speaking to one
person and not the entire room. One
person, one thought, then move. That one
habit will instantly make you look more
composed, sound more believable, and
feel like someone people actually want
to keep listening to. Trait number two
of high-status communicators. They know
how to activate your imagination. When I
think about some of the most charismatic
and magnetic influential people I've
ever come across as a keynote speaker
and a communication coach, they all have
one thing in common that they all do.
They don't bore you with the facts and
the figures. They bring the information
to life with analogies, metaphors, and
similes. They don't give you a bullet
point update about their life. They take
you into the moment and then they relive
it with you through storytelling. They
don't speak in vague concepts. They are
highly specific, which makes what they
say more memorable. High-status
communicators understand how to activate
the imagination of their listeners to
keep them engaged and locked in. They're
not just delivering information, they're
creating an experience for you to
receive the information in the most
memorable way possible. And look, I can
spend all day going deep into every
single technique to activate people's
imagination. So, let me distill for you
the 80/20, the 20% of techniques that
gives you 80% of the results. Number one
is specificity.
When you're describing anything to
anyone, people love it when you get
specific. For example, if I asked you,
"How was your day?" and you responded,
"I was stressful. It was the worst,
actually." To make that more specific,
you could respond by saying, "Oh, I had
a really stressful meeting this
afternoon with some senior leaders, and
it was extra stressful because the CEO
was there. And the moment I sat down and
I opened up my laptop and I looked at
them,
I could tell from the lack of expression
on their faces
that they weren't happy with me. Notice
in the example where I was just a little
bit more specific about my day, my day
became suddenly easier to understand and
remember, and you felt like you were
there with me, right? And now, number
two.
Analogies,
metaphors,
and similes.
These are tools that allow you to make
the complex simple by comparing it to
something that is more well-known and
easier to understand. For example, I
always hear Peter, my director of
content, say things like, "I feel pretty
overwhelmed at the moment. Then, I have
to do everything on my own, filming the
content, editing projects, scheduling
the videos. There are so many things
that I have to do that I'm starting to
miss all of my KPIs." Instead, he could
use an analogy, a metaphor, or a simile.
Something like this, "Then, I feel like
I'm being sent into battle by myself
with no reinforcements. And instead of a
squad and actual weapons, I've been sent
into a war with twigs. And as a lone
wolf, I'm definitely going to die in
this mission." Doesn't that paint a more
vivid picture of the situation that he's
actually in? And to be honest, whether
or not Peter uses an analogy, a
metaphor, or a simile to tell me that
he's stressed, I'm still sending Peter
into the war by himself as a lone wolf
with bloody twigs.
>> [laughter]
>> Godspeed, Peter. And number three,
storytelling.
Here's the rule. If you want your point
that you're making to be more memorable,
use a story if the situation allows for
it. For example, if I met with my team
for a serious meeting and wanted to
drive the point that small communication
mistakes destroy your reputation, I
could literally just say what I just
said,
but would that be effective? Instead, if
I used a story like this, watch what
happens. Guys, I want to talk about
something serious that happened last
week. A certain someone on the team made
a post on Facebook and it reads, "Let's
eat dogs." Obviously, they were missing
a comma and they misspelled dogs. It
should have been spelled "dolls." And
then now everybody thinks we eat dogs
for lunch, which is wrong and
disgusting.
Because we eat dogs for dinner.
But the point I'm trying to make here
is, guys, these small communication
errors that you make, Batman, they're
going to cause damage to my reputation.
So, every time we post something
publicly, spelling, punctuation.
And then, take off that mask. We know
it's you.
>> Yeah. We definitely push the boundaries
here on this channel and I'm okay with
it. How much more effective was it when
I used a story to get the point across
compared to just saying the point? So,
stop it with the boring communication,
give specific detail, give me something
visual that I can see in my mind with an
analogy, a metaphor, or a simile. Give
me the sound, give me something I can
imagine with my senses. Make the complex
ideas and messages simple and fun to
understand. And if you dare, tell a
story to get the point across. Don't
just say the point. Trust me,
storytelling is the ultimate weapon of
influence in a communicator's toolkit.
And the final trait, number one of
high-status communicators, is they
aren't afraid of silence.
This.
They aren't afraid of it. This is one of
the clearest signals of status that you
can hear. And I want to show you three
real life examples of where three great
communicators used the pause
strategically. Watch how they unafraid
of it, and how much aura they have
because they simply just pause.
>> Perhaps you could tell us what you
personally have been doing for the last
7 years.
>> Uh
You know,
you can please some of the people
some of the time,
but
>> How did it feel to be here tonight? What
does it mean for you?
>> How did it feel for you?
>> Well, I have to say you were my
childhood crush. So
>> You got to stop, man. We're you know, I
can't get these ads because of some of
the things you tweet.
>> You know, I'm reminded of
>> How powerful were those pauses? Most
people don't do this. They get nervous,
they rush, and then they fill every
single gap with an um, uh, like, so, do
you know what I mean? Because they feel
uncomfortable with silence. But did you
see those people embrace the silence?
Even if you are credible, and you know
what you're talking about, if you fill
the silence with auditory clutter, to
the listener, they hear you as
uncertain, unprepared, and scattered.
I'm going to give you five reasons why
silence is actually your best friend.
Reason number one, when you pause
between your sentences,
it gives what you say next
more weight.
Notice how I paused before I said more
weight, which emphasized those words
even more. Reason number two, when you
pause after your sentences,
it makes it easier for the listener to
follow you because it gives them time to
process what you just said.
Notice how you're processing the moment
I paused?
Notice how you just did it again? Reason
number three, when someone asks you a
question and you pause before answering,
it signals respect, it signals that you
have control, and that you are
comfortable holding space. And combined
with that, reason number four, pausing
before you answer gives you time to
think more clearly before answering,
which allows you to be more deliberate
with your words and prevents you from
rambling. And it shows you're putting a
lot of thought into the answer. And
reason number five, I think is the most
beautiful of them all. Because beyond
you being able to reduce the filler
words, you also sounding more credible
and more thoughtful, when you train this
behavior and you start to pause more
when you're speaking to someone, you're
actually creating space for people to
share more with you. For example,
sometimes when people talk and they
naturally pause, often what do we do? We
just immediately butt in and we start
talking because again, we're
uncomfortable with the silence. Whereas
what happens when you start to become
really comfortable with
when people are talking and you don't
respond straight away, even after
they've finished talking, you just
pause. What you're doing is you're
leaving space for them to be able to
fill if they want to. And what you'll
notice is, as you start to do this, as
people even seem to finish their
thought, because there's still more
space, they keep going. They share more
with you, more depth. As you learn to
embrace the silence, over time people
will start reading you as being more
confident, thoughtful, and composed.
These are the five traits of high-status
communicators. Learn how to speak with
conviction. Vocal certainty, it builds
trust. Learn how to say more with less.
Verbal precision makes you more clear.
Strengthen your visual presence through
eye contact. Activate the imagination of
the people you're speaking to and learn
how to be comfortable
with silence. If you're just starting
your journey to become a better
communicator, it can be really difficult
to spot where you need to improve, which
is why self-awareness is the first step
you need to take. So, click the video
just up here and I'll teach you how to
build self-awareness so you know exactly
what you need to improve.